are you ready for the first-ever public
III Nintendo and Microsoft definitely
are I'm Tony and this game spot news
update is such a tease first up
Microsoft executive Phil Spencer took to
Twitter to say quote I want to give our
games more time on stage at e3 I
sometimes feel like we rush telling the
story of our games but don't expect just
software from microsoft either with
project Scorpio launching this year a
segment dedicated to Hardware just makes
sense on the Nintendo side nintendo of
america president Reggie Fiza may spoke
with fox news about the company's III
plans saying it has quote big things in
the works considering III is just a few
months after the switch launch it's a
pretty safe bet that that's what
Nintendo will focus on with less time
devoted to the 3ds and be sure to
subscribe to gamespot for any further
announcements from both of those heavy
hitters speaking of Lynch Sony and some
other big publishers have teased their
e3 showcases as well with EA planning
another EA play event before the
conference itself kicks off and speaking
of EA why not check out the latest
episode of reboot all about Mass Effect
Andromeda
[Music]